all right let's now move to Trump's next
weekend appearance he appeared last
night on The Mark Levin program on Fox
News this you have to see the topic of
Richard Nixon came up
um the disgraced former American
president and Trump delivered a
two-minute word salad that is almost
Beyond linguistic comprehension this may
be Trump's worst interview of the year
it's only April but folks that it'll get
worse but this may be Trump's worst
interview of the year so far let's
listen to Trump's completely confused
word salad when the topic of Richard
Nixon came up uh he was a very tough guy
he was I guess some people would say
this about me too he was his Own Worst
Enemy I mean I could say that a little
bit about myself much less so than
people think I will say but
um he was
sort of a paranoid guy and that's okay
you know you keep your guard up that I
don't say that badly this is just an
electric amount of energy from Trump as
you can see you can also tell Trump's a
real history buff
uh his views on Henry Kissinger were
very interesting I won't tell you
exactly I get along pretty well with
Kissinger but I tell you his views on
Henry Kissinger were not so hot and uh
he was a tough guy and he he they went
over to tell him that you have to get
out his biggest regret according to his
daughters and I think according to him
pretty much was that he didn't fight
they went over there one evening Barry
Goldwater headed up the delegation and
they had some senators and some
congressmen and they went over to tell
him he's got to get out
and he left the following day or the
following morning
and his biggest regret was that he
didn't fight
because it wasn't really like him
and I find that very interesting
and his daughter when I got impeached
twice by by the way it's not that Nixon
didn't fight yeah Trump the history
above Nixon fought and fought and fought
until courts made him turn over the
tapes that shody was complicit complicit
in the Scandal and leaders of his own
party approached him and said we will
impeach you if you don't resign Nixon
did fight but the Republican Party had
the strength of will or the moral
Clarity I mean I don't want to overstate
it to say hey you you got to go it
wasn't made up of lunatics like Jim
Jordan and Marjorie Taylor green at the
time but Nixon did fight yeah really
crooked disgusting politicians you know
they just happen to have a majority and
they the Democrats do stick together and
they want a perfect phone call think of
it on a perfect phone call this was a
call that I remember Tim Scott the
senator from South Carolina read this he
was the first one to say he read the
call because I had it it was taped the
code was taped
he said he didn't say anything wrong he
was saying like what did he do I was a
perfect I was a congratulatory call but
I'll never forget uh
when that happened we had such great
support Nixon had no support you know he
just didn't have support he was very
very tough with people just an endless
circular word salad uh I get along with
people I mean I I have great Jim Jordan
and all his congressmen are great
they're really incredible people they're
fighting so Trump did there's more but
it will stop it there just electric
energy from Trump as you can tell then
as I told you earlier the topic of
dictators came up
and I kind of like this question from
Mark Levin to a degree where he points
out you seem to really get along well
with genocidal Maniacs what's up with
that and I know Levin's not even really
trying to be tough but it is a funny
moment take a look at this and look keep
an eye on Trump's reaction let me ask
you a question about that you have
really fascinating letters on here from
Putin
from G
from on in North Korea and I can go on
and what I notice there's a Common
Thread
you had a personal relationship with
every one of these leaders whether
they're genocidal Maniacs whether
they're elected like Abe of Japan who
was a close friend of yours and was
assassinated I want to get into some of
this
why would you say your foreign policy is
because I think people keep projecting
onto your farm power well Trump has no
idea what his foreign policy is
basically he just lusts for
authoritarian power and that's why he
admires these tyrants I'll see what it
is that they think they want people to
think your foreign policy is
what would you say it is so I think more
than anything else and it was a very
personal relationship and you know it
was sort of a weird situation the
tougher they were the better I got along
with them and that's probably a good
thing because it was a tough one so it
had the big powerful countries the ones
that can do destruction yeah this is so
much simpler this is so much simpler for
whatever reason you want to say it is
and you could say it's because of
Trump's relationship with his father you
could psychoanalyze you could you could
come up with 20 different reasons as to
why
Trump is enamored with these
authoritarian strong men and sometimes
they are genocidal dictators he's
enamored with them Trump's not impressed
with diplomats like Angela Merkel or
Justin Trudeau Emmanuel macron he's he's
not it's not impressive and in fact
Trump's relationships with our
historical Western allies were
significantly uh damaged while he was
president and the U.S was increasingly
not even a part of many important
discussions with our historical allies
while Trump was President Trump was
enamored with the dictators and the
authoritarians and that's fundamentally
what it is and we could psychoanalyze
back you know until the as long as the
day is we could sack we could uh
speculate about that
but that's the reality one more weird
moment from this interview with Mark
Levin on Fox News Trump says that China
raped America and I got it back in the
form of taxes tariffs and other things
and with hundreds of billions left over
and no other president got 10 cents and
yet I got along with President XI
incredibly well but I was stopping the
Rampage it was the rape of America
that's what it was it was the yeah the
rape China raped America is Trump's
latest thing these interviews mark my
words are going to get more and more
insane as Trump's legal troubles worsen
potentially with more arrests and
indictments and if Ron DeSantis does get
in the race which I don't know that he's
going to we'll talk about it if if
DeSantis does get in the race it will
also be hugely triggering to Trump
one of our sponsors is betterhelp I am a
huge believer in therapy let's say
you've been thinking for a while about
getting into therapy you know it's the
right move you have things you'd like to
talk to someone about there is no better
time than the present but you don't have
to drive across town every week and sit
in a waiting room because of better help
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists specializing in a wide range
of issues you answer a few questions
about yourself and better help will
match you with a therapist based on your
specific needs and preferences the
sessions can be on the phone video call
chat anytime anywhere from your couch at
home from your office at work and if
your therapist isn't the right fit you
can switch anytime at no charge my
audience gets 10 off your first month at
better help.com slash Pacman the link is
down below